[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello martin are you doing
okay
i don't know you'll have to inform me
well you look okay so i'll go by the
looks then that's fine
we've had a question
of uh well actually not one a few people
have asked us
to give an overview of the great
controversy
so
today
let's take some time
and discuss
that controversy
the
great controversy how much time do you
have martin
well the book the great controversy will
probably take you a good few weeks or
months to read so i hope not we don't
have that no we don't have that we have
to in a short time get to the basics
of what other people have studied for a
lifetime yes and the whole
controversy
has been
for ages and it is hotting up
correct it is reaching a climax
let's open with a word of prayer our
heavenly father thank you very much for
all the opportunities that you give us
to have these discussions
we ask that you bless us you enlighten
our minds and in this important topic
that you will
help us to discuss it to give
a good overview of what's going on in
jesus name amen amen
martin how many millions of people have
spent
lifetimes studying this topic
many many millions how many lives have
been lost in the process yeah since the
beginning of
the world all right
so
if you take the garden of eden martin
two brothers
and
what started in heaven
continued down here
and brother against brother
sister against sister
war hatred death suffering
it's been a terrible terrible
catastrophe
this is the question that people have
was it necessary for god
to allow so much suffering i mean it is
in his power
just to end it right yes he could have
nipped it in the bud yes with lucifer
already all right
so
why did he allow this catastrophe to
continue
and
why the
accompanying
human woe
why the tears
that are associated with it
so to give an overview of the great
controversy is not an easy
task is god arbitrary
does he make arbitrary decisions
no
or is he a god of
meticulous order
is he a god of compassion
or is he a tyrant yeah and we've
discussed this in
lecture of the lecture of the lecture
some people have this tyrannical view of
god
and some religious systems have this
kingly hierarchial
view of god
calvin had that yeah
and wesley had
this loving view of god
and these ideas have been clashing with
each other
for centuries
and those that sit on opposite sides of
their view
clash with each other
to the point where millions and millions
of people are murdered and martyred
because they don't see it exactly as you
see it
that's actually sad yes that you can go
so far
on your opinion
to take the life of somebody else all
right so let's start with this very
basic question
is the jury still in session
when it comes to the character of god
yes
all right
are there whole religious systems
that claim that their
view of deity is the correct one and
everyone else must be killed by the
sword if they don't follow that view yes
all right then you have the aggressive
and you have the timid and you have
everything in between
right with that as a basic
let's start with
the biblical story
and you know when you start with the
biblical story you pick up the bible
correct isn't that correct
nothing else yes you start with the
bible
correct
now you can start in the book of genesis
but then you won't get a view of of the
exact character of things that comes a
little bit later in the bible
so one should actually go to
ezekiel chapter 28
and it says here in chapter 28
the word of the lord came again unto me
saying son of man say unto the prince of
tyrus
thus says the lord god
now it's talking about the prince of
tyros here
but we will soon see that the the prince
of tyrus
cannot conform
to all the criteria
that are mentioned over here so he's
used as an acronym
for
someone else
in other words
this is a typological story
which finds a literal fulfillment and
enactment in an earthly situation
but has a deeper meaning
so this is the story of lucifer
thus says the lord god
because thine heart is lifted up
point number one
here's someone who has lifted himself up
who's arrogant right
assumes a position that is not his right
yes
and thou has said i am a god
in my bible here which is the king james
it's written in a capital g
so here's a an individual
who is arrogant
and claims to be
a god
not only that i sit in the seat of god
he takes the throne yes
in his mind at least he takes the throne
in the midst of the seas
in other words all the created beings
the nations the peoples the multitudes
and then it says
yet thou art a man
and not god
i set thine heart as a heart of god
it's just in your
nature to elevate yourself
behold thou art wiser than daniel
now
that is really something
solomon was a very wise king ryan yes
but daniel was also given wisdom and
understanding yes and the bible is very
clear in the book of daniel that daniel
had wisdom and understanding
there's no secret they can
hide from thee
so
he's very intelligent
he has understanding
he has a character which is problematic
without wisdom and with thine
understanding
thou hast gotten the riches
and has gotten gold and silver
into thy treasures
so he has enriched himself
and this this is a reference to an
earthly king yes but referring to a
higher power
now this attitude is something
that prevails
inhumanity to this very day
so somewhere on the in this world you
might have aprons
or maybe more
that have the same characteristics
some of them are very very rich
and they're constantly concerned with
the poor
yes
but thy great wisdom
and by thy traffic
has thou increased thy riches and thine
heart is lifted up because of thy riches
now this traffic is merchandise
so he's a merchant
and the bible in other places tells us
what his merchandise is yeah it's gold
and it's silver and it's all the
spices and everything and the souls of
men
yes exactly right
therefore thus says the lord god because
that set thine heart as the heart of god
therefore i will bring strangers upon
thee the terrible of the nations and
they shall draw their swords against the
beauty of thy wisdom
and they shall defile
thy brightness
they shall bring thee down to the pit
and thou shalt die the deaths of them
that are slain in the midst of the seas
wilt thou yet say before him
that slayeth thee i am god
but thou shalt be a man and not a god in
the hand of him that slayeth thee thou
shalt die the death of the uncircumcised
did you see that that is plural martin
yeah
it's interesting eh
yes thou shalt die the deaths of the
uncircumcised by the hand of strangers
for i have spoken it says the lord god
so it's a reference to the second death
there yes
and
it's talking about the earthly tyre
king
or prince but of course it also talks
about the other one
now let's have a look at
his attributes
we read them from verse 14.
thou art the anointed cherub that
covereth
now martin the cat's out of the bag
right correct it cannot be the literal
king of tyre not prince of tyre
so he's not just an ordinary cherub he's
a covering cherub
now there were two
cherubs that covered
the ark of the covenant yeah
so in other words
this cherub
was one that had
a view
the closest view
of the character and the law of god yes
and yet
he acted contrary to that law
by coveting the position of god
you shall have no other gods besides me
right yes
and then it says thou wast upon the holy
mountain of god that has walked up and
down in the midst of the stones of fire
so this cannot be an earthly king no no
he walked up and down
in the midst of the stones of fire now
someone in the bible that walks up and
down
is someone who claims
ownership great
right yeah
so if you bought a piece of land
you would take your shoe off
and hand it over before witnesses
and give it to the person that bought
the land put that shoe on and then you
walked up and down the land
there was the deal
thou was perfect in thy ways from the
day that thou was created till iniquity
was found in thee
now that is a very
profound statement
perfect
that means without sin
from the day that thou was
created
so he's a created being yes
and he's not god right no
till iniquity was found in the and this
debate has been raging
for millennia
who put the iniquity there
according to this text
nobody put it there it was found in him
then the question arises
well
if god created him
and it was found in him then god must
have put it there right that's the
that's the debate in calvinism
and uh
who's responsible for the fall did god
create man to fall
did he create lucifer in order to be
found with iniquity
or what is this mysterious thing that
happened here
this strange
thing that interfered with perfection
so what was it how did it get there
now the first question i would have for
you martin is
was
this entity lucifer
was he capable of exercising his will
yes
he proved it right correct
was he capable of
exercising that will contrary to the
will of god yes
he proved it right yes
doesn't that prove that he has freedom
of choice yes
okay so i had freedom of choice yes
now if he had freedom of choice
and he was perfect
then he was without sin right
he was perfect until
that word until implies a time period
yeah
until iniquity was found in him
so the iniquity was it placed there by
god
or did it arise when he started
exercising his will contrary to the will
of god yes that's when he started
exercising his world contrary to the
will of god
it was always there
so god never started exercising it god
never created it no
but we can say that god created the
potential yes for it to develop yes
because
of free will
all right so
we have now come to the conclusion
that god
did not create the iniquity it was found
in him
but god created the potential
for the iniquity yes
okay
now was that a clever act or a stupid
act
i understand your question because if
you it depends on how you look at this
now and what your view of god is
because
if you've got a loving view of god
you'll know that
this is not the issue he
definitely would have created it was a
good idea
now
martin if he created the potential
knowing full well if he is
an all-knowing god
that it would lead eventually to this
catastrophe
because this is just the beginning
we're talking about the great
controversy and overview you have to
have a beginning and you have to have an
end right yes
and you have to have unfortunately an in
between correct
if he knew this
and he did it anyway
created that
being with that potential
then it must have been a very important
point to him
definitely
because that would prove something to
him
so this freedom of choice
that he instilled in this created being
was of such paramount importance to god
that he was prepared to suffer the
consequences
for a particular period of time
yes
and he was not
a god who was not going to become
involved in this
he was prepared
to bear the consequences himself yes
right
now there are a couple of attributes
here and we read them down
to verse 20.
uh that that flow out of this out of
this desire
to elevate yourself
constantly when you read the bible the
lord
warns against lording it over others
it shall not be so
with you right yes the kings of this
world
they lord it over others they command it
shall not be so without you is there a
tendency
in in people to to laud it over others
definitely
and in some more so than others right
and has the world seen its fair share of
tyrants
definitely
i think the world is quite
tired of tyrants at this stage well
how many tyrants does it take to
convince humanity
that this elevated view that's why i
wanted to say well because
you won't say that the world is tired of
it by the way it's carrying on no it
continually
gets somebody to be a tyrant over there
correct we had a we had a discussion
just the other day in one of our talks
here
where
we put post benedict up there
and he was talking about his elevated
view yeah and why he has the authority
the moral authority
to do this that and the other to dictate
not only in terms of theology but also
in terms of politics correct
look at these attributes here by the
multitude of thy merchandise
and we've already discussed that
merchandise
they are filled the midst of thee with
violence
and thy sinned therefore i will cast
thee as profane out of the mountain of
god and i will destroy the o covering
cherub from the midst of the stones of
fire
now
this is a very
very direct statement as to what the
consequences eventually will be for this
attitude yeah
but there are
rock songs
which are called sympathy with the devil
and if you read all the occultists
throughout history where did their
sympathy lie
with him with him
this is amazing isn't it so here it says
thine heart was lifted up because of thy
beauty
and that has
corrupted thy wisdom by reason of thy
brightness
now here's a description of this being
does does this line up with the with the
image like buffomet for example no
not at all no so
if you have constantly depicted yourself
or this being
in this evil way and then one day this
being of
magistic beauty
and brightness appears wouldn't that
flaw some people yes
definitely he's a master of reversal
isn't he
thou has defiled thy sanctuaries
martin he's talking about churches
and it's talking about thy sanctuaries
his sanctuaries
does he control many religious systems
in the world
according to this yes
okay
by the multitude of thine iniquities by
the iniquity of thy traffic
therefore while i bring forth a fire
from the midst of thee and i shall
devour thee
and i will bring thee to ashes upon the
earth and the sight of all of them that
behold thee
what is the the basic
theology in the world about the survival
of this evil being is he going to be
destroyed like this or will he have
eternal life in a in a fiery pool he'll
be
actually ruling
the
everlasting fire
so martin don't you find it amazing that
the world has managed to distort this
teaching beyond recognition yes into the
exact opposite of what it says
he is the master of reverse exactly
right
okay so we're not going to continue
there but we can go to isaiah chapter
14. we're just
laying some groundwork about the
character
of the great adversary
where the story is actually
unfolded in a slightly different fashion
if we read from
verse 11 which deals with this entity
thy pump is brought down to the grave
and the noise of thy vials the worm is
spread under thee and the worms cover
thee
this is this final destruction
and then it gives this description
how art thou fallen from heaven o
lucifer
son of the morning
how art i cut down to the ground which
did weaken the nations
and i you know when i read that albert
pike comes to mind
the grand master of freemasonry
lucifer
yeah and he says strange
that this being of light
should be called the being of darkness
is it he that bears the light doubted
not
twisting it around right completely the
opposite completely the master of
reversal again
for thou said in the heart i will ascend
into heaven i will exalt my throne above
the stars of god
talking about the angels and here you
have this
this parallel between stars and the
angelic host and we pick it up in the
book of revelation as well
i will sit also upon the mount of the
congregation in the sides of the north
now the north is where the throne of god
is
so he will sit in the mount of the
congregation
so there where the godhood
sits
he will sit
he will be in the congregation
he will be
in the bishop's seat if you like
he will be the overseer he will be the
one calling the shots
do we have that kind of thing happening
in the world today yes and it's been
there for millennia
and they're sitting in the in the north
they sit on a great white throne martin
with cherubs on either side
do we have a power in the world that
sits on a great white throne with
cherubs around it with four living
beings sitting around him
i will ascend above the heights of the
clouds i will be like the most high
yet thou shalt be brought down to hell
to the sides of the pit
all right we don't have to continue with
that for the moment
we have laid some groundwork as to
the character of the adversary so let's
go back
to
the beginning
and again
we have to we have to go here i cannot
resist it let's go to the book of
revelation
and go to chapter 12.
and in chapter 12 we have
the great controversy between the people
of god
and
the people that belong
to
the devil
and it's the story about god's people
the woman the church that flees
from the wrath of the dragon
and the dragon is of course the great
dragon this terrible being verse three
and they appeared another wonder in
heaven
and behold the great red dragon having
seven heads and ten horns and seven
crowns upon his heads
and his tail drew the third part of the
stars of heaven and it cast them to the
earth
and the dragon stood before the woman
which was ready to be delivered for to
devour her child as soon as it was born
now martin this is a very interesting
story because this dragon we are told is
the devil right
it is defined as such
the serpent it is the serpent it is the
devil that great deceiver
but he uses earthly powers and in this
case the great red dragon was rome
and it was the power that was used to
try and destroy
that child that would come the messiah
but then we have a little bit of detail
in interconnected with it he took a
third of the stars he wanted to rule
over all of them
he ended up with a third
and they were cast out
and then we read in verse 7 and there
was war in heaven michael and his angels
and we had a whole what's up prophet
about who michael was so we're not going
to go into that
michael and his angels the two-thirds
against the dragon and the dragonfort
and his angels and prevailed not neither
was their
place found any more in heaven
and the great dragon was cast out that
old serpent called the devil
and satan which deceiveth the whole
world he was cast out into the earth and
his angels were cast out with him
so there was a war in heaven
so
there was a clash
between these two concepts and we've
we've laid some groundwork now
all right let's go back
to heaven
before this world was created
there was this majestic being
and he coveted the throne of god he
wanted to sit
in the congregation but he wanted to sit
on the throne of god in the north
and he felt that it was his right
and he was a covering cherub
he had a very good view
of god's requirements
and god's eternal wisdom and law
and yet he rebelled
but
by his insinuations
by his craft
it's interesting and we talk about a
craft right
by his craft he had convinced many
angels that his cause was just
so there was a controversy
and it was possible because he had
freedom of choice
and he exercised that freedom of choice
and therefore god
allowed it to ferment to the point of
open rebellion
because the angels that he was deceiving
also had a free choice and they had to
make a decision
so they were looking like this
they were looking like this
and eventually it boiled over to the
point of war
and eventually two-thirds sided with god
one-third sided with the devil and he
was cast out of heaven
and then god created
this world
so this world was not an afterthought
and we have to ask ourselves the
question
why
did he create
this world
well number one martin the devil was
cast out
he must have been cast out to somewhere
right correct so where was he cast out
well the bible says
that when god created this world it was
formless
and it was void
and darkness was over the waters it was
a dark place
a dark place is some some place where
god is not present because god is light
light yeah
so is it that the darkness had been cast
out to this place
and then god said all right let there be
light
in the midst of this darkness
now where there is light
god is present yes
all right
so god wasn't going to allow the
darkness to continue forever
but now you have a serious situation you
have two sides
in a
controversy you have god and his angels
on the one side
and some of those angels are still
confused yeah
because obviously for one third of the
angels went they all heard the arguments
and some of them were probably
confused
so god could have knifed it in the
button he could have destroyed satan and
the rebellious ones but then he would
have had a government of fear for all
eternity
whoa
if we dare
to think in the way that they thought
then death is the consequence now fear
never conquers
only love
conquers correct
so in other words now there were two
sides now normally if you have a
serious dispute
let's say you and i have a serious
dispute and it cannot be resolved
amongst us what do we normally do in an
earthly situation you get a third party
you get a third party
to act as go between to sort out this
issue in other words
there needed to be a third party an
impartial third party
was there an impartial third party in
heaven
no
there were only two there were only two
sides right
there was no impartial party
so what's the solution to this problem
you have to get one create one
all right
all right now if you had want an
impartial third party
in any court of law
when you go to a court of law
the two sides
will state their case
right so there will be an advocate for
the one side and an advocate for the
other side
now in this particular case the two
parties had to
state their case
but there was no one to state it before
so god in his wisdom created it but if
he had created them like the angels and
taken them to the heavenly court and
said i want you to observe this
this would not have worked it had to be
an independent
source
so he created them
man
and
woman
and he shared something that he hadn't
shared with anyone ever before the
capacity to bring forth offspring
yeah and then he gave them rulership
this had never been done before
never yeah
he gave them rulership
dominion now the word rulership
rule
implies rules
yes isn't that right correct
because you cannot rule unless there are
certain criteria to rule by
and this was the unique aspect of
humanity
yes because if you actually look
at any organization or any movement
if it doesn't have rules set down it's
totally chaos in there yes
so the issue
in heaven
had to do with the rules
and the argument that lucifer had
is i'm an exalted being
i don't need to have a set of rules to
live by
i'm a ruler to myself i will decide who
are you to decide for me what is right
and what is wrong
because that must have been the case or
else you couldn't have had a war correct
right
it's logical yeah
and so he thought to himself these rules
that i've been a covering cherub over
because he was the one that implemented
god's rule
right he was the head of the angels i
mean god was over him but he was
the
the chief honcho
right
and the angels adored him yes
and you find a little bit of that
character in absalom
the people adored him yeah and went to
him for judgment
and he loved it to go and sit in the
gate to be the judge and to judge the
people and give them righteousness and
he said to everyone that came to him
that once david's too busy
i will give you justice
so here was this majestic being
displaying this kind of attitude
and so god
threw him out
and created a jury
and he said okay here is the situation
there are two sides
there is my government and you are
created by me
and there are certain rules
and we'll make it simple
if you believe me and obey me
then you will not eat of that tree of
the knowledge of good and evil because i
don't want you to know about evil
i want you to know only about good
but to be fair to the other side
at that tree there's an enemy
that will tell you another side of the
story
now just the way
it unfolded
god saw them face to face
because he created them at the end of
the sixth day
and the next day was the sabbath day
yeah
so for a whole day
they spoke to god face to face
and god showed them their kingdom and
god
communed with them and there was nothing
hidden
nothing hit nothing
and they had a full glimpse
of
the one side of the story
and then eve wandered off to that tree
and received the other side of the story
did he really say that
you know what it's not like he said it's
the other way around you will surely not
die
and in fact you know what you've you're
just slaves
you're supposed to be obedient and not
do this and not do that look at me i can
do whatever i want i'll eat this fruit
but he comes as a serpent
he doesn't even come face to face is the
serpent
a being of
of uh the description that we read in
isaiah no
no
and
when he said to eve the serpent
the first
portion
when he asked her did god really say
that yes then she actually added a
little bit yes and then i touched even
the touch and then it was easier for him
to say but look i touched and i can
nothing i can even speak
and so
like many of the angels
she believed him
and he mesmerized her
he hypnotized her
into
wanting
something you know modern when we look
at our television screens in the world
do they constantly bombard you with what
you what you want oh definitely
definitely not with what you need right
because we've got so much junk we don't
need it exactly but
the one side yeah
so that's part of his character
for sure
but god permitted this
and he gave them rulership now why did
he give them rulership this must have
irked the devil
yes
now modern rules and regulations
and responsibility
that was
god's intention
in creating this jury
and the devil had no insight as to how
it was going to be created this jury
he was furious right
because there were a few things
that must have really bugged him number
one
the creating capacity of god
was given to this new creation yeah they
could bring forth life
he couldn't do that and
they were given rulership
something which he coveted
yes right
now why did god do that
because in any situation where you have
responsibility
there you will need rules
you know i always use this very simple
example if your child says it's going to
play ball on the highway
then you will tell him
that that is not permitted and if he
tells you
he's a law unto himself and will decide
for himself whether he can do that or
not
then the board of education sometimes
becomes a useful object right
yes
so rules are sometimes enforced
not because you hate your child but
because you love him love your child so
this was something
that enabled them
to make a decision as to whether god is
just in having a set of rules and
regulations or whether he is tyrannical
this should help right correct okay
but they lost their dominion
they seeded their dominion to this other
power because the bible tells you
that if you obey someone his servant you
are yes
and so
this being
that had been thrown out of heaven
became the representative in the
councils of heaven of this earth yes
incredible story
and god permitted it
yeah
what does that tell you about the
character of god
he is loving because he again permitted
free choice is he fair definitely he
allowed this being to be in the counsel
of god and he said to him the book of
job what you're doing here yeah
and he's arrogant answer walking up and
down
what does that say
ownership i'm the lord and the master of
this place
i am the lord and the master
and even in spite of the fall
not because of the fall
because you can learn the lessons of
rulership
even without the fall yeah because if
you had these children
and you had to organize
your dominion
then you would have had to work
according to rules and if you were
a being of love then those rules would
have been
a yoke of lightness
so even in this situation
god permitted it
but he had to show the universe
what the consequences would be
if you
lived outside of the rules which god had
established yes all right
if i'm just thinking of it when you say
there's
the rules
i'm thinking of a hedge
yes
and it's protecting
what's inside
and that's the rules
and when you go out of those rules over
the hedge
then you're in the open field and all
dangers are upon you
okay that's a very good point that's why
the bible uses the wall and the hedge as
an example
of that hedge that he planted around his
people
so you find that image in the bible
where he says i planted a vineyard gave
you a church and i put a wall around you
which is the law
so actually it's a very
intriguing story
but now there was
a greater catastrophe
humanity
had ceded its rulership
to this tyrannical power
and the consequence was
death
the very first
children
murdered each other cain murdered abel
and two camps evolved
and out of those two camps
there has been a situation of war since
that day to the present
and you still have two camps yeah
and the evil side is unfortunately
always in the majority
and portrays itself
as the benefactor
and makes rules and regulations because
that is their right as rulers
correct they are become rulers of evil
yes
but their rules are tyrannical
contradictory to god's god's rules
and humanity is caught up in this
situation
and they are the jury
they are the ones who are to decide
either for the character of god
or for the character of the other
multitudes
multitudes side with the adversary
in this great controversy
and you know martin we showed them on
the screen
and we showed the rock stars
and we showed how they give their power
over to this being
for the sake of what
that same
thing that started in lucifer
to be elevated to be higher to be
famous
exactly
isn't it interesting that when they
achieve that status
they are called stars
i don't think it's a coincidence oh no
it's definitely not a coincidence and
idols
and idols idolatry
it is it is fascinating and
and what are they boasting
with
themselves
and who gave them the capacity to sing
who gave them the capacity to do all
these things god
now it's fascinating to me that some
that can't even sing
that croak like frogs
still can become stars if they give
themselves over to this power yes
and some of them receive capacities
beyond their human capacity and can play
the guitar and admit that they can play
that guitar
better than they themselves complained
because another entity takes over
isn't that correct all for the sake of
what
fame
for how long
so fleeting right yeah
and the jury
is out
the jury is looking
now martin
this is a very
different jury
to normal juries
normal juries sit there
and very often they are even protected
okay
but this jury
part of the
the situation
this jury
has to
feel in its flesh
the consequences of one choice over
another choice
this jury has to witness
how their own offspring
makes decisions
either
for glory
or for calamity
and there is
nothing
they can do about it yeah
you can chain your child
to the wall
but that will not gain the heart so the
only thing that that will win the heart
is freedom
you have to give
freedom
of choice
if you want to win the heart of someone
you have to give them freedom you can
never win someone's heart
without giving them freedom no
definitely not
how many relationships in this world
are supposedly working
because
the one partner is caged
but open that cage and the bird will
fly away
how do you prevent the bird from flying
giving it free choice
and giving it love exactly
it wants to stay there okay now what
about the prodigal son off he went give
me my money give me everything i'm out
of here
where did he end up
in the big stay
and then one day and he came to his
census and he said you know what i'm
going to make a choice here it was
better in my father's house were there
rules in his father's house yes
when he came back did he say whatever
you say i will do
yes it is
so had he come to the conclusion that
the rules that he rebelled against or
better than the rules he ended up with
definitely i can take myself for on that
my dad used to say
you mustn't drink so much and go and
party the whole time and then end up
late at home
and drive
yeah yeah yeah and how many times did i
end up crashing the car
having to
phone him to come and help me and stuff
and he always used to say you just
pushed the limits too far
i
remember i once came up
and
i had the key
and i was looking for the keyhole
yeah i couldn't find it
and when i looked up i was pushing the
key into my father's navel
this is a very different jury
and the sad thing about this planet
is that
it is escalating
the controversy
as we come closer to this final point of
destruction because we just read
that this covering cherub and all that
belong to him will be destroyed
that's god's decree
now had he done that in the beginning
he would have had a government of fear
yes
if he does this at the end
will it be fear or a sigh of relief a
sigh of relief
i think we're already there okay
all right so this is the essence of the
great controversy
a decision has to be made as to the
character
of the two adversaries yes
and there are only two sides
that's so important
only two
doesn't matter you can have a thousand
organizations
and they can be seemingly at loggerheads
that's just a distraction
they all have
one master
or they have the other master that's it
that is the choice that needs to be made
even the ones that do not want to choose
a side
unfortunately will fall into one of the
sides
there is
no
halfway
measure you cannot sit on the fence
like martin luther said you better
choose one side
you either hide behind the devil or you
hide behind christ trying to make peace
between the two means to be crushed
compromise is impossible yes
i mean how often do we read
that compromise is impossible
it's impossible
so the great controversy
is all about
a decision
and as the world moves towards
a
tyranny
are we moving towards the tyranny
definitely we are moving towards tyrion
so do you feel more and more boxed in
yes locked down
yes
it's yeah
isn't that interesting is freedom of
choice starting to
disappear
the freedom of choice
that we have in the world today
is conditional definitely i just heard
today
that we in this country can now fly to
11 countries again
on condition unconditionally
let's not go there just to say on
condition
anything you do
is unconditionally
yes you have free choice
unconditional but if it doesn't fall
into the condition sorry your free
choice doesn't mean anything that's
right so common good right
common good so the world has to make a
choice
now once you've come to the conclusion
that god's way
is the only
fair way
you actually have to not only choose
between rules you have to choose between
the leader as well
yes
now it's interesting to me
that roman catholicism
teaches ultramountainism
all power in one man
because martin
people say a camel is a horse designed
by a committee
and it might be good to have
you know a committee to decide things
but very often
it gets to the point that someone makes
the decision correct and this is where
rome comes in and says this is the way
it's going to be
so as i said there is also a choice of
leader
that is associated with this and and men
love choosing leaders
yes don't they
it's actually
stunning
if you look at it yes people are
okay with it
if the leader rules over or dictates
over them for 40 years or 20 years
but they want that leader they want that
leader
now when adolf hitler came to power
he came to power because he promised the
people
many many things and he actually stepped
up to the plate and fulfilled many of
the promises right
after the first world war
the situation was dire
particularly in germany because the
taxes and everything that they had to
pay and the retributions were so high
and the people were poverty struck
he restored many of those things and
they put their total trust on him and
what what happened eventually they
called him fira fiera yes which is our
leader
so here
they were willing to do anything
to go
to war
to sacrifice themselves
for a cause in eugenics
unbelievable
and if you take mao zeitung
or lenin or any one of those
despots genghis khan
all of them you always had an and
napoleon you always have a leader
and then you have a conqueror correct
and if you take
american politics
who when they feel that someone is
strong they they want to follow him i
mean trump had a tremendous following
right he still does he still does
so people want that
now martin is it important to you
to know what the character of the leader
is like
yes
now
when it comes to the great controversy
and the character of god
and the character of the other one
we've seen what the character is like
that was described now
when god
went past
moses and he showed him his character
and
this god that is so kind and forgiving
and all of these attributes
and
he shone
with the light so that you couldn't even
look at his face right
when this god condescended to come down
to this earth and to bear the
consequences for himself
and you look at the stories of the
gospels have you ever
anywhere in any literature
come across
the lead character
and the character of the lead character
that even closely resembles
the one of jesus
no
was he
a strong
individual yes very strong very strong
did he have strong principles definitely
was he afraid to
expose wrong no
did he laud it over others no
did he admonish his followers not to
laud it over others yes
did he lead by example
did he love
to the point of death right
so if you look at the cross
the cross negates all the arguments
coming to think of it a lot of people
then sees love
as weakness
love is strength
because they will say
for instance i mean his own disciples
they thought he was going to be king
and they maybe have thought of it's a
sign of weakness
that he got crucified well they actually
did
yes and judas to the point of betrayal
he wanted to force his hand
and that's important to know in our time
when a leader
is there
and wants to
get rid of people or sort out all these
things that's not the character of god
no
so martin
basically the great controversy
is about a decision
it is about a personal decision that
everyone has to make individually
the facts in the great court case are
open to everyone
you can switch on the media you can see
the consequences of the great
controversy
you have the greatest love story ever
written right here
explaining the great controversy
it shows the outplaying of the conflict
to the point of death in the gospels
it gives a portrayal of the character of
god which many call weakness
so modern that which seems
such a contradiction in terms
is actually where the strength of god
lies yes you know
if we go to
second corinthians chapter
let's just go there
where paul is talking about the thorn in
his flesh
and he says in verse seven and lest i
should be exalted above measure through
the abundance of the revelations
there was given to me a thorn in the
flesh
so lest he become like lucifer
correct wanted to be because he was so
exalted he had such an abundance of
revelations
he knew more than anyone else
i mean this is something
that can make you lift it up right
to prevent that the lord gave him a
thorn in his flesh
the messenger of satan
to buffet me
lest i should be exalted above measure
so here we have a lesson in character
development right
so it is absolutely
paramount
that god
give us lessons in humility
lest we develop a character like his
adversary and he surely does do it all
right so if you have a position
of prominence then expect some thorns
yes right
and you know when god i always say when
god gave us children he gave us knees
because without knees you won't be able
to survive
i found this fascinating
and then it says in verse 8 for this
thing i besought the lord thrice
that it might depart from me
please take it away
i'm perfectly capable lord
of being fine without this thorn
and the lord knowing human nature says
sorry
i think you need the thorn yeah
and i'm sure the first two times
he was getting frustrated
and now the third time after you've
asked he said
then comes this verse and
it's written in red the answer
and he said to me
my grace is sufficient for thee for my
strength
is made perfect in weakness
now martin
do you think
a president of a country
who would stand up and say that
no
and nobody will say that of the
president if he said this he'll say
don't mess with me i have an army behind
me
exactly
my strength is made perfect in my power
and in the military might of my
armaments it's also interesting now that
you mentioned that like that
all these leaders always have a big
voice as well
so martin this is the greatest
contradiction
that you can probably find anywhere my
grace is sufficient for thee
for my strength is made perfect
in weakness
now martin
who are the disciples weaklings
yes
and
no
yes
when were they weaklings
when it had to come to faith
when it came to faith yes but before it
came to that point they were full of
bravado exactly they were puffed up so
that's why i say yes and no because they
weren't weak when it came to maybe
physical being physical like peter
but when it comes to
being humble
they were weak
all right
now when did they become strong
after the crucifixion after they
realized their weakness they became
strong
and that strength if it's measured
by humans
is actually weakness
correct
so
the great controversy often appears like
a contradiction in terms
but the final analysis
has to do
with the character of the one in charge
and if you look at the world today
and you have to make this choice
it is to me
so sad to see how few there are
that are willing
to take
the burden of the yoke of lightness
yeah that's well put just take a simple
thing like the sabbath
how much
of an attitude and how much of a war is
there against the simple command
remember the sabbath day it's astounding
isn't that astounding
just
just keep this
day it's it's not a war a war right
take any one of the commandments
idolatry
or
take the commandments of life
it's my body yeah i'll decide what to do
with it
take
the laws of health
don't tell me what to eat i will decide
what to eat
don't eat the blood
that's what makes it tasty don't tell me
what to do i mean the rebellion is
all the way
and all the time
god is made out to be the tyrant correct
and this is it
god says okay
you want to go against it
go for it
the consequence is disease
sitting with arthritis
pain
suffering
tears at the grave
and yet we will not learn you know it's
astounding to me the devil started with
this reversal and we still sit with it
because everything that god said whether
it be food whether it be the sabbath is
always turned around correct and made
bad and no we've got a better choice woe
to those who call evil good and good
evil so let's sum it up martin
there was a war in heaven
and the war was about the government of
god
the character of god
as a ruler
was on trial
you're not a benevolent god because you
have rules
and if you make rules
who are you to enforce them upon me
that was it yeah
that same war unfolds or unfolds itself
in every single household with children
there comes a point when the children
say who made you ruler
i was sitting with my son and his four
children and his wife
and the wife gave a command to one of
the children
this little child
put their hands in the side and said who
made you the boss
and this great controversy just flashed
before me and
i had to smile
that's because that is the reality of it
this war has been raging ever since the
beginning
and very often
a parent has to let go
and
conquer with love
because
if you try to conquer and maintain
through coercion
do we have court cases in the world
going on now where parents control
certain people we discussed if we don't
have to go into that detail i actually
think
if i
correct she lost the case correct so so
you cannot control someone
by coercion
you can only
win this battle with love
[Music]
and if i had to look at the two
sides
and the characters of the two sides
and i see how the world stage is
portraying those characters
then i have come to the conclusion
that i will serve
the master that was prepared
to die for my freedom of choice
and if the world will decide that
everybody who makes that decision
and who accepts that free choice
that free gift
of eternal life
will be safe to have around in heaven
no coercion
no puffed up individual he thinks he's
the bee's knees
regard for the neighbor yeah
selfless love
that's the kind of environment that you
will choose
and god will have the right
to destroy this world
and even if there are tears he will wipe
them off
and then the lion
and the lamb will lie next to each other
and they will not hurt nor destroy
in all my holy mountain in his kingdom
and that'll be the end of the great
controversy when that fire comes down
from heaven
and the enemies
are destroyed ashes come and sit at my
side at my right side till i make your
enemies
your footstool and you know
that
obliteration of enemies
doesn't bring
joy to god no
it is the bible calls it his strange act
but the whole universe will say fair and
just
are your judgments amen
let's close
heavenly father
we are all a part of this great
controversy
there are no spectators
only participants
and we can all feel
a fraction of the pain
you have felt it for millennia
from the foundation of the world
and we have felt it for
a short period which is called this life
but the final
issue is a choice
the jury has to sit
the jury of the mind
and decide
for the party of their choice
help us to make right choices
in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again